[Music]
J GRE so lovely to be here with you
today thank you so much thank you so
let's start at the beginning tell me
about how you founded your company yeah
sure I took computer science for the
first time as a freshman in college and
it was super super difficult for me I
always felt like I had to work like
twice as hard as other people many of my
friends also felt the same way and this
kind of affected our self-esteem for
years afterwards right cuz I think the
way that you're taught and your
education can have a huge impact on your
sense of selfworth and how you see
yourself and so we provide tools and
curriculum to teach computer science and
AI to middle school and high school
students so we try to empower teachers
to teach the subjects and students to
learn the subjects we want to make those
those intro classes in particular
accessible and motivating and something
that kind of builds self-esteem and it
you know I I truly believe these
subjects are something that anybody can
learn and and everybody should have a
fundamental understanding of how they
work because it's a huge part of how our
world
Works you're selling into school
districts correct yeah yeah currently we
like our biggest partnership is is a
partnership with the state of Tennessee
we went through an RFP process with the
state so so pretty much the state chose
us as their provider for computer
science education so they're actually
going to have a graduation requirement
starting next fall which requires every
single high school student in the state
of Tennessee to have to take computer
science to graduate which is like that's
huge how many states and schools are you
in right now so Tennessee is we have
that whole state partnership with the
state of Ohio has actually us used one
of our our courses as well one of our
many AI courses too we're speaking to
New York California spoken to Arkansas
as well as other countries too so East
and West Africa as well as in Asia so
there's there's a lot that's
amazing can you talk to me a bit about
any metrics to show the scale of your
company can you talk about how you've
had sales growth or Revenue growth or
user growth yeah yeah so I would say
with have had about 2.5 to 3 million in
sales talk to me about your fundraising
Journey what's that been like and how
much have you raised our most recent
rounds was our series a and it was 15
million and I think so far we've raised
about 21 million you dictionaries
instead of using IFL statements to check
if a key exists inside the dictionary
what's it like to be a young woman in a
very male Centric Tech field especially
young woman too yeah yeah so I actually
I worked at JPL I was one of like a few
women out of like a group of about 30
and it was it was it was tough but I
also think it's so important to have
mentors and people who who support you
when we visit schools in Tennessee right
like I get to talk to the girls taking
those classes and they come up to me and
like we chat and I think that is kind of
what keeps me going is there one piece
of business advice or a rule that you
always operate by no matter what yeah
there is and it's it's going to sound
simple but it's really to treat people
well and with respect and an empathy and
I think like whether it's business or
personal I I I truly believe this and
maybe I'm I'm privileged to have
experienced this and believe this I
think if you treat people well treat
them with respect and empathy then the
right people will surround you and the
right people will support you that's
actually I mean I feel like we talk
about that in our courses too because I
think Ed one big role education has is
you know I mean kids are learning these
different subjects a very important time
in their life so it's important to to
show them that like kindness and empathy
can go a long way too so that's and I I
think it it can go a long way in
business you know professional personal
so that's totally agree it can be really
applied to anything yeah it sounds
simple but I think it's it's really
really important to remember on a
day-to-day
basis last question for you what would
you like your legacy to be what would I
like my legacy to be I think this maybe
ties back to the piece of advice it's
going to sound simple but I guess I hope
I can be somebody that helps other
people believe in themselves a little
bit more I think education has a big
role to play in that so I think if we
can create a product and courses and
curriculum that make people feel like
they have the potential to be who they
want and do what they want that'll be
great that and I just hope I can be
someone that's empathetic and kind and
can help others do the
same
n